in this video we're going to talk about
one of the most important ideas in
mathematics and that's whether order
matters when you multiply two numbers so
for example is 3
times 4
the same thing
as four times three are these two things
equal to each other and regardless of
whether these two are equal to each
other is it always the case that if i
have some number times some other number
if i swap the order am i going to get an
equivalent number
well pause this video and see if you can
work through that try to think about
that a little bit before we think
through it together
well let's think through this particular
example and we're going to do so with
the help of some angry cats
so we clearly see some angry cats here
yes they are angry we could view this as
three groups of four
so this is one group right over here of
angry cats four angry cats
this is two groups of four angry cats
and this is three groups of four angry
cats if we view the first number here as
groups of the second number but we could
also view it as four groups of three how
would we do that
well we could have
one group of three angry cats we can
have two groups
of three angry cats we can have three
groups of three angry cats and we can of
course have four groups of three angry
cats so based on that if you think of it
the first number as groups of the second
number well it seems like the order
doesn't matter another way you could
think about it is here you have four
rows of three angry cats you have one
two
three
four rows
of one two
three angry cats and so to figure out
how many total cats you have you
multiply four times three but you could
view this same group of angry cats but
just view it with a slightly different
perspective
so here we have our angry cats
and then let me rotate our angry cats
probably risking making them a little
bit angrier let me move them back in
and now we could view this as
three rows one two three of four cats in
each row so we let me put all of these
up right so we have one two three rows
of one two three
four cats don't wanna look at those
because it might make us a little bit
confused and we're dealing with the
exact same number of cats and so i'm
only dealing with three and four here
but what you will see is order doesn't
matter when you are multiplying two
numbers and we could also see that on a
number line and we could do that with
multiple examples
i'll keep a couple of angry cats here
looking at us just to keep us keep us in
check
if we want to think about 3 times 4 we
could view it as 4 3s
or we could view it as three fours
four
eight
and twelve and i focused a lot on three
and four but we could do it with any two
numbers that we're trying to multiply
together so let's say we wanted to do
that with
i don't know let's see
six whether six times four whether it's
the same thing as four times six
well you could view it as six fours
four
8
12
16
20
and then 24
or you could view it as four sixes
one six 12
18
and 24.
so big takeaway order doesn't matter
when you are multiplying numbers like
this and this is sometimes referred to
as the commutative property it's a fancy
word but it's really just saying that
whether you're doing 6 times 4 or 4
times 6 the commutative property of
multiplication says hey those two things
are going to be equivalent
meow yes they are angry for being
rotated